the Joe Rogan experience the opinion is
there was something so dope Ted we could
just break it down to one in the [ __ ]
like what was the thought process button
well from my point of view right it was
just like that's how for my point of
view music was being devalued right the
streaming service of our society right
do streaming of course right illegal
download illegal downloads right if you
want to let's talk a little bit of
business I won't go through but give me
two minutes of business all right so
let's just take Napster right who's the
founder right this type of technology
right
and he takes millions of songs and gives
them away and then now people are
getting all these songs for free now the
music industry like any other industry
has a certain quota of business it does
every year like every other industry
right well there's four billion dollars
a year five billion dollars a year it's
the industry of a group of people and
that's their yearly quota
so if Napster comes right and and and he
takes all these songs where all these
people who are waiting for their
publishing checks waiting for their
economics to be created for music there
there's no publishing check all the
numbers are now decrease because there's
no physical sell of their music for us
to accumulate a value to send you a
check but then at the end of the day
after he does that he gets a billion
dollars so now you took in what belongs
to let's say say there's a thousand
artists that's worth value and far as
you know that sell records that you
could say accumulate money right so he
took it took the power of a thousand and
put it in one man's hand okay so that's
one of the first mistakes as an industry
we make and then the second mistake we
make is that now their services going
and there's illegal downloads and people
won't pay a dollar for the record right
right and for album you won't pay ten to
twelve hours for album even the sale is
$20 you won't pay that but you pay 300
400 hours for your headphones well two
three hours for your eye
your phone and you using it for music
let me ask you this what's that without
your headphones without music you have
posters useless right so why would you
not pay the 10 20 hours for the music
cuz they don't have to write because
they don't get it some other way but let
me ask you this what is the best way to
support artists what's the best way to
buy it well the best way to buy it now
know your music Tang Clan anybody's
music what's the best way get the most
out of it well the best way in the past
was physical but now the industry has
figured out how to monetize the Digital
streaming so now things are starting to
rebalance but during this period of time
though maybe within the last three four
years it's starting to rebalance but if
you look at from 2000 to 2015
there's a total unbalanced right and a
lot of artists had to stop making music
because there's no economics right now
I'll group like the wu-tang clan right
so let's just say let's say the average
very small a wolf a purr you know let's
say you'll remember get it let me get 16
you might be Yellin tell he don't know
what 16 is - yo don't be 20 cent for
that right okay
20,000 Joe okay so now let's just say he
got 10 verses on this album
you know I'm a let's say every other
room member do the same so to get to get
our album made it may cost a million
dollars a studio session a studio
session is up to let's say at a cheapest
level 100 bucks an hour you do it to do
a 12 hour block out that's another grand
a day just to get into the studio you
got your engineer there you got so it
costs money to create music right but
now you get all this done and you want
to sell it and somebody just the world
just takes it for free so now you can't
recreate it again now even though the
tools have gotten easier now and you
could do a lot with your laptop and all
that even a laptop is - geez bro even
though the download just logic right
with everybody you $200 man and so you
need a social it so so it's merchandise
and brand now it's merchandise and
it's merchandise and being able to take
the idea of that brand if you're a fan
but if you're a fan what's the best way
discipline arrow whenever you what's the
best way to plan what's the best way to
support is it Apple music like what is
what is the best one iTunes know that
you now narrow everything gets found
this way other words that you could
stream is good and you can stream it
Spotify skills modifier is good you
could download it directly to your phone
if you were using attractions to fans
like what's the best way to support
wu-tang clan what's the best way to
accumulate music acquire music I mean
they're all good now like streaming yeah
I think it's balanced obviously the
tunes how's this Amazon look music is
the second thing the catch-22 here Joe
is this okay
now music is also made to be heard yes
so while at one point I try to prove a
point by saying look I'm gonna put a
value on it so you know there's a value
to it because there's a value to me but
then on the other point right we put I
put another album out called it better
tomorrow which is like y'all do what you
want with that you know outcome because
I don't make music for me to listen to I
make it for the world and listen to it
at the same time so the best way to
support your artists is just by
listening to the music alright would you
it's beautiful but so this is good
though this is cuz I've always wanted to
know this cuz I've always I've always
been like what do i do do I do iTunes do
i do amazon like where do you get the
most money back from yeah I think look I
think the system has found the way to
balance itself okay so it's okay now
yeah so Spotify is good you know sliema
you know Sleeman look you know I mean I
think even Taylor Swift is thinking
about coming over to the swimming thing
that dirty girl come to streams yeah
because because because that's the way
to listen now as long if she gets a good
deal right I'll be like you said just
the whole thing in the day is play fair
yes like you know what you can say I
don't want this streaming service but
somebody has to have a platform for
people to even come check for you yes
things need to know fancy knowing what a
give I'm a fan and you know $14 is not
too much money for me to spend I need to
know where to spend it I would if I
could
if there's one place you could tell me
that's the best way to support wu-tang
clan it's like
as a fan right this fan and I and I had
the money to spend you know I would
definitely you know I would buy the
vinylright Wow because it's tangible
right oh wow because it's there's a
tangible spending money right okay
you get a by physical of yeah a physical
for physical especially a record like
you buy the vinyl yeah there's a killer
that's so funny that you said it because
I know people of certain blah blah blah
is like this oh [ __ ] they want audio
rights to something
so taking put it on vinyl and then the
value is the history the story like a
[ __ ] one of vinyl wu-tang
because it's art just like what they
don't do one joint its
and like you say we talked about it
earlier it's coming back yeah it's
coming back now I'm not saying go to
clubs or anything like that and a DJ's
like that but the act of collecting
something to take it take home with you
some member CDs CDs is like this
technology is about to die why would I
buy this CD because it has a booklet
remember part of what albums were was
are yeah it was artwork and picture weed
on it boo they give you a giant piece of
rolling paper yeah yeah and that was the
last thing and I don't see what you did
but I don't see people doing that but I
think it's gonna go back nobody's
everybody's not gonna have 12 hundreds
in your house or whatever but some
people especially if it's a genre or
something did you connect with they're
gonna be like I'm gonna buy that
[Applause]